so what are some of the big myths about
the the porn industry that you think are
not true oh man
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today used to
be known by her uh professional name Eva
lovia uh Candace hallback welcome to
trigonometry you are of course a former
porn actress and now turned podcast and
commentator yes thank you guys for
having me it's so good to have you on
the show listen before we get into it I
should first of all say you're the only
guest where I haven't said I'm a huge
fan of your work for obvious reasons uh
but but also tell everybody a little bit
about your backstory who are you how are
you where you are what has been your
journey through life lead you to be
sitting here talking to us oh man okay
so I guess like 10 000 foot view would
be I've spent over a decade in the in
the adult industry
um I kind of navigated the mainstream
version of that and then slowly
transitioned to self-producing and now
the only fans model which is you know
very um popular right now lot of people
are talking about that and then I would
say somewhere in the middle of that I
decided to start a podcast just like
everyone else you know during quarantine
and lockdown so I I got inspired to do
it mostly because
um I just saw a lot of conversations
that were being had on one side and I
feel like no one was really representing
thoughts that I thought were important
conversations that I thought were
important or asking tough questions
because I'm in this rare space where I
can't be canceled so I was like well
let's see what we can do with that and
um and run with it well we like people
who can't be canceled because they're
the ones the the only ones nowadays who
can have an honest conversation which is
what we tried to do so very much in that
Spirit can you just start us off by
telling us some basic stuff about you
know what how did you get into the into
the adult film industry and why what
motivates you to do that
oh man it was
um it's gonna sound kind of crazy but to
some extent I've always been fascinated
by sexuality and kind of the energy and
power that comes with that even from a
very young age I was often like
idolizing women like um Pamela Anderson
and um Carmen Electra and the Playboy
bunnies and I don't know I I've felt
like there was some kind of Freedom that
came along with like realizing your
sexual potential and then for me it just
it seemed like that's just who I was it
wasn't for the money it wasn't to get
super famous it just kind of felt like a
part of me so I kind of dipped my toe in
with just like implied modeling like
something that you would see in
magazines you know not showing anything
and I just kind of got bored and I was
like well that's not what I really want
to do I want to do these big pictures
and I want to be doing these big movies
and I want to see what it's like to be
on a proper set
um so I reached out to a company in
Florida and I was like I don't really
know how this works like do you audition
like how like how mainstream is this how
does it go and I they really just send
us a couple selfies and I did and then
they flew me down to Florida and the
rest was history and so how long did you
work in the mainstream industry for
oh man I'd say probably
five to six years it was pretty short
I've spent probably just as much time
now on the opposite side of it just
self-producing and doing the more
amateur approach as I did in the
mainstream industry
and whenever there's been an expose of
the porn industry on TV it always looks
I'm going to be using technical language
here can do so it looks [ __ ] awful
is it actually like that it looks deeply
exploitative it looks deeply
misogynistic and nobody comes out of it
in a good way or is that just an
industry the TV trying to moralize
trying to put this narrative across so I
think two things can be true at once
right and I think being exploited isn't
unique to the adult industry especially
when it comes to women I think
um you know we can be harassed in any
industry it's you look at you know the
music business or look at mainstream
Hollywood
um anywhere really it can exist I think
it's just it has more of that visceral
response because it's such an intimate
industry so we really don't like when we
see it and it's happening
um quite literally right like you have
an assault or something that happens on
set so I mean that absolutely does
happen and it's not to take away from
the people that are victims within like
the sex trade but I wouldn't say that
that's the norm I wouldn't say that the
vast majority of porn is leading to
human trafficking which seems to kind of
Be The Narrative right now and if that
were true then if you were to look at
countries like Nepal where porn is
illegal you would expect that there's no
trafficking right and there would be no
women or children that are being
exploited but that's really not the case
they have a huge trafficking
um issue in that country
so uh yeah I think I think both things
can be true I think it depends on why
you got in too right like if you go in
because it's a curiosity or it's a part
of like something that you want to
explore versus I have a bill to pay and
I'm just doing this out of survival I
think the outcome is going to be
dependent on that
and I mean you talked uh I was watching
one of your interviews where you talked
about performing with one particular
person I think in the UK and you were
saying that this person was you know not
respectful not a good person and made
you feel deeply uncomfortable was that
the norm or is that actually an
aberration and most people in it are
just professionals it started turning up
to the office you turn up with your cup
of coffee you're walking and you do what
you need to do
so I think my case is a little bit
unique when I started shooting more of
the hardcore stuff I always had a yes
list so everyone that I would work with
that was a man was
um had to like check off certain boxes
for me so I was very particular who I
was going to work with in the states I
didn't really know anyone when I came
over to shoot in the UK so I kind of
just had to ask around as to like who
who people would recommend
um for one of the bigger pictures we did
someone was on this or I got booked with
someone that I didn't really know
anything about I was like it won't be a
big deal you know I've been doing this
for years now it was just a scene right
and I don't know if it was just
I don't know if he was trying to act or
if he was nervous maybe because of who I
was because I was a really big name at
the time
um and he was a UK performer and they
don't really have the same amount of um
like like star power quote-unquote
um so I don't know what was going on it
was really uncomfortable no one really
said anything so I don't know if that's
normal for most women if they just work
with random people that show up on set
um I know that was very unusual for me
because again like I had a yes list so
everyone on it was like a superstar like
very respectful very professional would
never put Me In Harm's Way and this is
just one of those rare instances where I
worked with someone off of my list and I
was like well this is why I have a list
this is why that exists
so it sounds like you were in a position
of actually quite a lot of power uh
compared to many other people I would
imagine an industry being a big name Etc
do you think that that is prob possibly
why you had fewer issues with that sort
of thing do you think that it's more
common for for people sort of lower down
the pecking order to be exploited I mean
as comedians it's obviously a different
industry but I can tell you it's kind of
the same like the lower down the pecking
order you are in comedy the more you
know you get asked to do things for no
money you get asked to do things that
you're not necessarily Keen to do to
travel further then you'd like all that
sort of stuff so do you think that you
were sort of somewhat insulated from
some of the problems that people often
associate with porn because of who you
were
definitely because I mean even the stuff
anything dicey that I even did have to
go through through my career I think
that's it's actually got fired from my
contract
um and it was one of like the final
decisions before I started
self-producing so I got fired because I
was like one of the main and like
original contract girls for my era of of
porn star
um and we started getting new contract
girls and I just saw stuff that I wasn't
okay with and then I saw what they were
doing to me I saw what they were doing
to her and I was like well if they're
doing this to people that have these
really large social platforms I can't
imagine what they're doing to someone
who has nothing right because they don't
they they can shout into this void and
No One's Gonna know
um so I took to Twitter about it sorry
to interrupt by making them do things
that you were uncomfortable with what
are we actually talking about here so I
would say like something really simple
right like a contract so they sent me my
contract and I had to obviously send it
to my lawyer and have it reviewed and
make adjustments and send it back and
they acted like this was Preposterous
right like no one does this you just
signed was like well that's ridiculous
they should right so this girl
um that was getting signed her agent was
like no no no just sign it you don't
need to send it to a lawyer Eva's just a
diva like don't you don't want to be
difficult like that right so she signs
this contract I don't know what hers
said I know what mine said and I can
imagine it was pretty similar to my
original version
um typically when it comes to sex acts
and especially if you're contracted
everything is kind of laid out like a
menu so it's like okay this act is for
this price and all of these are my yeses
all of these are no's like don't even
bring it to me I don't do them
um so for example it it seems obvious
but if you were to work in a group scene
you would expect to get paid more money
right and if it's not listed you would
expect that that conversation would be
had if you were comfortable with that so
I was in a particular situation where I
showed up across the sea right I show up
in the UK and all of a sudden it's this
huge group scene and I don't do those
and they're like well you're already
here you have to do it I was like that's
not how it works so it was like this
huge argument obviously I didn't end up
going through with it because that
wasn't you know that wasn't something I
was comfortable with
um but the other girl did because she
you know didn't want to cause a stir and
she didn't get paid extra and it's like
you were being taken advantage of so
clearly
um and she was such a sweet girl she
didn't want to be disagreeable you know
she wanted to keep her head down she
really loved what she was doing she
loved her opportunities you know what I
mean working for this very large company
um so I was like well if no one else is
going to say something I'm going to
so it sounds like uh can you start to
interrupt it sounds like exactly the
sort of thing people experience in every
industry uh across the Spectrum I've
been in those positions and often found
myself being the odd one out as well
which is why I've ended up doing this
but but but the problem is for me at
least and to you know talk to me talk me
out of this if you can that you know if
someone wants me to to work for less
money or do this or do that at the end
of the day I'm not selling something as
intimate as sex whereas here someone is
being put in a position where like you
say there may be sweet maybe they're a
little bit fearful of upsetting people
Etc and the end result is they end up
having sex with a bunch of people that
they never wanted to in the first place
and that I think is where a lot of
people have the feeling that porn is
uniquely exploitative would you agree
with that
I think it depends on the mindset so
it's gonna maybe sound a little callous
or I don't know I just think some people
can have very casual sex and it doesn't
leave a trauma right like they can be
they can kind of dissociate
um and then other people can't I would
say most people can't so it depends on
the person I would imagine yes if I felt
like I was in a position where I ended
up having sex with five people that I
didn't want to like I can imagine that's
a really big regret and then how do you
deal with that I don't know
um especially because you like let's say
you leave the industry and you go to a
society that's not really accepting of
those decisions so now you kind of are
Cast Away
um so I would say like it's it's very
easy to blame just the porn but you also
have to take into account everything
after the fact right like do you have a
support system to go to do you have a
community that's willing to let you
um to give you Grace so it's it's like a
very weird and big problem yeah I hear
what you're saying but I it's I it
doesn't sound quite right to me in the
sense of like well sure you want a
community of supportive people but at
the end of the day I don't think anyone
wants people to be in a position where
they're encouraged or coerced or forced
or whatever the word is to be doing
things sexually that they don't want to
do totally I think that's where a lot of
people have an issue with with the with
the industry of porn that sure you can
have supportive people Hold Your Hand
afterwards and you'd hope everyone gets
the support they need but in the real in
the ideal world that wouldn't be
happening in the first place
right and then you would have to also
say though is that is that unique like
again it feels it feels different right
because it's such an intimate industry
but if you talk to some people like this
one girl
um before she got into like the sex
industry she was working in like a
basement Factory for 16 to 18 hours a
day for like eight bucks an hour
um she never saw the sunlight like you
can't like trauma exists everywhere
right we have people that are suffering
from immense amounts of depression
anxiety
um lack of purpose and fulfillment and
they're really hurting and I wouldn't
say that that's unique to just a sexual
exploitation I think you can be
exploited anywhere and it just feels
worse because it's your body that's
being exploited but I could argue that
like if your soul or your mind is being
exploited that's just as bad
but I suppose the one thing that I would
push back on you there Candice is let's
say that you you go and work in a
factory you know we've we've all done
menial jobs I certainly have they're all
depressing you know it's unfulfilling
etc etc etc
but if you're pushed into when you're
doing pornography into something that
you were not comfortable with that you
feel as if You Were Somehow being
degraded there's the extra element where
that content could then be uploaded to a
site like PornHub and then it could be
watched by potentially millions of
people doesn't doesn't that also come
into play oh 100 and I I'm really
hopeful with the way that things seem to
be moving when it comes to like
decentralized platforms and blockchain
that that is going to be like a huge um
alternative to the current model because
I do think that there should be some
kind of of discourse if let's say you
have one of these scenes right and there
was something questionable that happened
or maybe you were abused or maybe you
weren't consenting like that should be
taken down 100 it should be without a
question
um unfortunately we obviously know that
doesn't happen we know that PornHub had
to delete a whole bunch of videos
because of this and even stuff that you
might see on like a site like browsers
or Bang Bros there's probably a lot of
young women that are like I wish that
scene wasn't out and there's no there's
no course for them to even have that
conversation you can go to them be the
contract that you sign prior to shooting
is like in perpetuity this is going to
exist in any unders any any other
industry you can't say in perpetuity but
with something that intimate you can it
doesn't really make sense so I think
when it comes to blockchain and nfts
you're going to have the creators that
are owning that content and that they're
going to be able to either add it or
remove it yeah and I was going to ask
you as well in terms of
um the the situation with porn and you
you met you started set at the beginning
that you you were addressing some of the
things that people sometimes maybe think
about that aren't true so what are some
of the big myths about the the porn
industry that you think are not true
oh man I would well the first and
obvious one is that everyone in it is
being exploited
um that's just not true again it exists
but I wouldn't even say that's the
majority
um I would say that the one of the more
recent
um talking points is that it ruins
masculinity or that it creates a type of
sexual autism which I feel like
um it's kind of cherry picking the way
that we're interpreting data so yes if
you watch a ridiculous amount of porn
it's to be assumed that you're gonna
show up a little bit different in the
bedroom and you might not recognize your
partner's cues you might be very selfish
you might not understand their
boundaries but that's not unique to porn
so if you spend a lot of time on social
media you'll actually show those same
signs in just regular conversations so
you won't be able to pick up on like
facial responses and other forms of like
non-verbal communication so yes that's
important but that's just like too much
screen time period
um so I'd say those are probably the
most common ones
hey KKK do you like feeling silky and
smooth like a sexual dolphin never talk
to me again what if I told you that
manscape to brought out a new and
improved lawnmower 3.0 that allows you
to be fresh and trim for the ladies down
below I'm married the last time I was
fresh and trimmed down below Jimmy
Savile was a respected children's
entertainer I'm gonna ignore that the
lawnmower has a Cutting Edge ceramic
blade which reduces the risk of having
an accident where you least want an
accident my bank account no you idiot
you know Los huevos oh right plus it's
waterproof which means you can groom in
the shower and it has an LED light so
you can really get an accurate and
precise trim x
sounds great what's the battery like 90
minutes so you can do your whole area in
about
seven recharges to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is a Force
Trigger 2-0 that is trigger 2-0 that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscapes.com and use our code which is
of course trigger two zero your huevos
will thank you excellent
you say that people don't get exploited
in and what is it is there an average
type of person who gets involved in this
industry is it like an do you have to
have an exhibitionist streaking you is
it somebody who has always wanted to or
is it as a mainstream media says you
know it's the girl who typically gets
into porn young who typically is
hypersexualized because of sexual abuse
Etc
oh it's hard right it's hard to like
break that down as to to how many people
are going into it with a level head and
they see it as a career and it's part of
who they are and they maybe are like
this
um they they're like this outlaw
personality right like they're more
comfortable on the fringes than within
the herd like that exists and then
there's some people that yeah maybe
maybe you are over sexualized by your
environment but like every part of our
environment influences who we are
whether it's like you want to become a
rocket scientist or an oil rigger or a
teacher right like you're constantly
being influenced by everything so to
just say that because of marketing
that's why you got into porn then we
would have a lot more people that were
in the sex work industry than what we do
right like it's still a very small
amount of the population
um so I think a lot of it has to be the
personality a lot of it has to be
um like you are again just more more
comfortable with that discomfort
and do you not worry when we were
talking about you know the effect that
it has on you know on the world it had
the effect it has on people's behavior
the reality is Pawn consumption has
exploded ever since the internet before
it was something difficult you actually
physically had to go into a shop buy it
Etc whereas now you can get it at the
just the tap of a screen that's progress
man
ah the accessibility issue is really
interesting right
um I think we obviously have guardrails
with everything that people don't
completely trust us with so there's
guard rails for tobacco there's
guardrail rails for alcohol right like
you can only have 90 proof or something
like that
um where I'm at in the States you can't
buy hard liquor on Sundays so at all
unless you're you go to a bar or
something but you can't go to a grocery
store or the liquor store and get it
just closed
um so there's guard rails currently I
feel like the internet and specifically
in the in the porn side of the internet
there's nothing right like everything's
free there's no time limit none of that
um
I'm a huge proponent of pay walls I
don't understand why there aren't any I
know it doesn't completely get rid of
the problem but I think that even if you
were to do like maybe like a
pay-per-view but that's kind of
you know I think that's maybe over
regulating I'm not really sure but just
like some kind of verification that you
know it's not a seven-year-old it's
someone who's at least old enough to
have a credit card and maybe some kind
of age verification process
um but I think someone who's maybe over
indulging in something like that like
that's just the symptom right so we have
to try to figure out why that's
happening like why is that avoidant
behavior you know showing up why do they
want to spend more time with themselves
in the screen and not with real people
um I don't think it's just porn right
you see that again with video games and
with people that are spending more time
in Minecraft and now you have meta and
we have this huge community of people
that just don't want to be in the real
world so why is that
it's a really good point and I I was
going to ask you do you think people
sometimes have a an inappropriately
unnecessarily negative view of the
industry do you think people sort of
demonize the industry sometimes for as
you say things that happen in many other
Industries oh 100 yeah
it's interesting that you say that
because for example one of our former
guests Dana Fleischman who is an
evolutionary uh biologist one of the
things she talked about in one of her
articles was that in societies where
there's a lot of porn consumption
actually violence against women's goes
down and sexual violence goes down
um so I I you know I I know it feels
like maybe we're sort of coming at you
from a moralistic angle a particularly
initially uh which we're not we're just
trying to you know probe the arguments
and find out what you think about stuff
uh but it's interesting so do you think
it's a weird question to ask but do you
think we would be worse off if we didn't
have porn
I think if you look at countries that
heavily repressed or regulate your
sexuality there's a lot more violence
and there's a lot less Freedom so
obviously you can't say causation right
all you can kind of do is look and try
to find patterns I mean with the boom of
the internet that's kind of one of the
things with the porn industry is they
tend to be on the Forefront of
Technology ever since the internet right
like that's what it was back in the 90s
and there was a drop of something like
80 something percent in sexual abuse and
and rapes in the U.S again you can't say
causation but it's just an interesting
pattern
um
so I think the conversation about like
is porn good or bad I think it's
whatever you want it to be I think you
are who you are and if you're a
misogynist and you are violent against
women I think that that's going to show
up in the content that you're watching I
think if you have a healthy relationship
with sexuality that's going to show up
in the content that you're watching
um so I wouldn't say it's I just think
porn is I don't think it it's good or
bad
but there are certainly certain
organizations or company out there that
you could argue have a malign influence
on society maybe like the company
PornHub they have got a huge amount of
critics where do you stand on a company
like that
so pornhub's an interesting
um interesting company so basically the
company that owns PornHub owns almost
all of the porn that you see online like
it's kind of one big Monopoly that
that's just like their biggest baby
um as far as Revenue goes I'm not in
favor of the tube model I think that
again they made all of their money by
not only pirating content stealing
content um especially from like small
producers like myself right like I have
this limited budget and they would maybe
take a video of mine and put it up there
for free where I charge for that and
it's behind a paywall and it's
responsible on on some level
um so just the way that they got started
wasn't very honest or ethical
I also think that when you're uploading
that kind of content with zero age
verification it's like what are you
doing like you're absolutely asking for
trouble
um so yeah I mean I I have a lot of
problems with the ethics of that company
so you said zero age verification
because this is something we have quite
uh We've we've hosted interviews with
quite a number of feminists we have
quite a a lot of feminists who watch the
show and engage with the show and it's
been said time and time again that
actually the PornHub have hosted content
featuring miners is this correct
allegedly allegedly please don't sue us
as soon as possible
so they did find videos of underage
girls of bright like that that was found
um I don't know how much was there and I
do know that's not unique to Pornhub
there's significantly more that was on
Facebook and all of those but the
difference is that Facebook comes out
and reports it
um because it's a problem that they're
trying to fix whereas PornHub was like
nothing exists here there's nothing to
see look the other way and you're like
well why are you not being honest about
this right like you can say that
something slipped through the cracks
because again that happens on every
platform it happens on Zoom it happens
on telegram
um like there's not a place in the
internet where there's not going to be
some like illegal content being
published so it was kind of concerning
and also interesting that again they
pretended the problem wasn't there at
all instead of just being transparent
saying like we want to help
um but yeah when you don't have any form
of verification like this is my content
I was consenting
um I was of age and and then you just
let anyone upload I feel like you're
asking for that content to be put up
and you mentioned several times the idea
of ethical porn and moving on from the
porn industry what was your reason for
for moving on and doing your own stuff
so I felt like I started having more and
more experiences where like my voice
wasn't being respected my boundaries
weren't being respected
um I was being told I was difficult all
of the time because I would say the word
no and I was I was just kind of over I
thought it was ridiculous I thought I
think it's ridiculous that performers
get paid one time for a scene that's out
there forever that absolutely will
affect the rest of your life not only
your life but if you decide to get
married or have children and your
parents like it affects absolutely every
crack that exists in your life and you
get paid one time so like there's no
royalties if there's anything that
happens you don't get to take it down I
just the power dynamic in that industry
is is still really off and then I saw
these third-party platforms that were
launching
and it gives the power to the Creator
and to the performer and it just seemed
like a no-brainer so I think that the
industry is definitely going to be going
through a revolution right now and again
when it comes to like crypto and
blockchain and nfts and all of this I
think that it's going to be turned
upside down in a very good way well one
of the things I'm told is happening in
the porn industry is uh there are a lot
of uh creators who are basically making
their own content in the same way that
Francis and I are now doing what TV used
to do we're having conversations with
people there's a lot of couples who are
making stuff which is just two people
who who love each other who are very
keen to do this they put their own stuff
out nobody's getting hopefully nobody's
getting coerced or abused or mistreated
in that situation and they're putting
out do you think that that's the sort of
direction that this all needs to move in
I wouldn't say that it needs to move to
just couples but I I definitely think
that's becoming a lot more common and I
think it starts to take the air out of
the wings of the people that are like
this is strictly exploitive
um because there's no case for that
there right everyone's of age everyone's
consenting they're actually married and
then it becomes very clear that the the
opponents of that industry it's strictly
like religious based
um where it's like it pertains to their
morality so I think you're gonna start
seeing that more because
it's just if you can choose to create a
to have a career or to lead the sexual
life that you want in like the most
isolated and
safe space like why wouldn't you like
why would you add unnecessary risk
um to that by shooting with people that
you don't know or for companies that you
don't know and you know giving away all
of your rights to your content so I
think it's going to happen for sure
um Candice what do you do if you know
someone takes some of your content and
puts it on a site but like PornHub which
is viewed around the world do you as as
a as a performer do you have any
recourse to say look I disagree with
this could you take it down or is it
once it's up there's
deal with it so you usually will have
your attorneys send in like a dmca form
and then in one to two days it gets
taken down and then as soon as it's
taken down it's back up and then the
cycle just repeats so pretty much once
it's there it's there it just comes down
for like these like really short moments
I mean
that's isn't that that's awful Isn't it
it's infuriating is it I mean but but
it's it's awful not just infuriating
because let's say you want to move on
from that let's say you have the period
in your life where you thought this is
what you wanted to do and because mainly
the women are young they're in their 20s
I mean who knows what you're doing in
your 20s and then you move on maybe you
want to become a lawyer or a doctor this
thing will hang over you for the rest of
your life yeah there's nothing that you
can do so it's like how do you solve
that problem and unfortunately people
don't really care so no one no one's
caring enough if you did that with let's
say like a universal picture it would be
it would be down there would be massive
fines and it wouldn't happen again that
doesn't exist in the adult space because
it's like people don't want to talk
about it repeat the argument is it
shouldn't be happening anyways like you
shouldn't be doing that
um you know you're immoral so you have
to deal with those consequences you made
that decision and I just find that to be
very unfair just like you said that a
lot of people get in very young you have
no idea what you're doing or what you
want to do at 18 years old and you make
a lot of bad decisions I think if you
make the decision and you end up saying
oh shouldn't have done that it's
something as intimate as having sex on
screen and you're like I own that I want
to take it down it shouldn't go back up
yeah that no I totally agree with you on
the one hand on the other hand look at
like Twitter I mean anything you say as
an 18 year old cannon will be used
against you for the rest of your life
right so I think we're all kind of stuck
in in that situation a little bit where
you can't do the but actually let's talk
about how you deal as someone who's been
in that industry because I know you're
you're a parent now and you've got a
family and all of that like how does
that transition even work
well so I was with my now husband
throughout pretty much my entire career
we had started dating
um so I feel like that's a little bit
unique I don't know what dating while I
was in my career especially at the
height of it would have been like that
would have been probably like very
um choppy Waters but to me there there's
of course like a transition that comes
with Parenthood just like anyone else
right like it's the person you were
before you had the baby and then after
it's everything's turned upside down but
the idea that you can't be this sexual
being and that side of you doesn't exist
after you have a kid is nonsense right
so it's like we have this very sanitized
version of what a mother is and that's
all she can be and I think that you know
there's a lot of facets to what we are
and we're this we're a whole person so
like that sexual side of me hasn't gone
away and didn't die once I became a mom
I think that makes people really
uncomfortable oh I'm sure it makes your
husband very comfortable but
no but my wife is is pregnant right now
so I'm very much hopeful she'd take
congratulations thank you so much but a
lot you alluded to the religious and
moralizing side of this and I do I'd
love to explore that with you because
I'm not a religious person and I've
definitely watched porn in my life and
at the same time I do have this like
little voice at the back of my head
going well actually this is kind of
wrong why do you think we feel that way
is it Acura or is it just something
we've been indoctrinated with or is it
you know some people would say well
everything to do with sex is so intimate
and sacred and special and and should be
between the people it happens between
like where does that that voice come
from I think we're influenced by so many
things we're influenced by our you know
our religions our cultures our societies
the countries that we're are born into I
think a lot of that has when you watch
them you know oh I don't know if this is
good or not or you feel dirty I think
there's still a lot of residual shame
when it comes to sexuality because of
our religious past but I mean if you
look I mean sex is just it it's hand in
hand with The Human Experience right
like it's almost the reason that we're
here is to procreate right like it
doesn't it feels good for a reason and
erotica has existed since we were able
to draw in in caves like that again it's
part of the human experience I think
when it started to I don't know be
judged or be painted with this brush of
fear again is when you had people that
were really pushing these Christian
views on everyone and on the pagans and
like you can't do this you can't have
these
um you know what were they doing like
those like naked Moon parties and they
would have all of these orgies I'm like
oh you heathens you can't do that here's
a Bible right and it's sex can be
whatever you want it to be there's
nothing wrong with monogamy there's
nothing wrong if you think that it's
supposed to be this spiritual
Transcendent experience and it can
absolutely be that thing but it can also
be something that's just frivolous and
fun and
um something that you're just taking out
you know for like a joy ride it can be
all of these things and I think that you
have to say like what is that shame how
is that shame serving you like is that
something that you want is that how you
want
um your mind and body to react when it
comes to digesting sexual anything
sexual right so
I don't know that's not the relationship
I want with sex I think
of course that's going to exist with
some content especially if you get into
like a really violent stuff or stuff
that's like very taboo and that's
probably there for a good cause but if
you're watching something that's will
say like ethical porn that you know
everyone is happy and you know willing
to shoot I don't see why
you would want that feeling or justify
that feeling
what about the fact that a lot of men
feel like they're cheating on their
partner by watching other people have
sex do you agree with that no at all and
there's this actually this is a really
interesting
um note by Esther perel so she was
saying in one of her talks that the idea
that watching porn is cheating is unique
to heterosexual couples that that
doesn't exist in in gay couples and I'm
like that's so fascinating
um
I think when it comes to like my mom's a
great example for this like she's one of
these women if she was dating a guy and
he's like oh Catherine Zeta Jones is
just such a babe I just love watching
her and Zorro just acknowledging the
beauty of someone else it would be over
it would be this huge fight that's you
know being unfaithful and that's where
she draws her line and the idea that you
can't appreciate other Beauty
without being unfaithful or without
somehow tarnishing the relationship that
you have I think is kind of ridiculous I
think do you want this really fragile
relationship or do you want something
that's anti-fragile so if your
relationship is that delicate we're
simply acknowledging someone else's
beauty or appreciating it or
masturbating to it is going to undo it
all I think that's kind of um
it's something to pay attention to
Candace do you think we're very
hypocritical with our attitudes to
section particularly for porn he doesn't
just mean the two of us
yeah I mean if you if you look at the
numbers right like if you look at how
many unique visits there are to Pornhub
I would say absolutely
and why is that why do we have this you
know because as you say you know we all
you know everybody has sex ever
practically everybody if you believe the
numbers watches porn why do we have such
weird attitudes to this
I think right now because again it's
still considered so Taboo it's still
considered something that is primarily
for the purpose of child rearing
um the idea that it's just for pleasure
is still not widely talked about even
though we kind of intrinsically know
that
um we know that pleasure is important uh
they've done all so they try to do these
sexual studies and they find that
there's this book called a billion
Wicked thoughts and they kind of took a
lot of these tube sites as ways to get
information as to what people are into
and Kinks and fetishes and all of these
things because even when you're giving
people what that you would call
Anonymous forms is they still didn't
feel like they could be honest
um so if there's like just something
really deeply buried in us that is again
linked to shame and judgment and we just
feel like we can't be ourselves and then
we wonder why we have unfilling sex
lives with our partners because we can't
have these conversations so I think it
starts with the individual and it's like
again how do you want to show up how do
you want your relationship sex to be and
you get to decide that you can undo
everything that you've been taught and
you can have this healthy relationship
with it and it doesn't have to be
something that's judged or shameful or
bad
you see
you would think that in 2021 that we
still wouldn't have such a complicated
attitude with the sexual act
do you think it's entirely to do with
religion or do or do you think it goes
deeper than that
that's a tough call I think
I think that we still have such a huge
and we're he's still hugely influenced
by religion so I think that you can't
ignore that
um especially still in the states like
that's I would say like the biggest
argument about it but I think we kind of
like jumped a whole bunch of steps ahead
so we went from let's just try to have
an honest conversation about we'll talk
about women's sexuality and like their
right to to pleasure to everyone needs
to have and only fans and if you don't
accept that then you know then you're
just a bigot and a misogynist and
whatever I'm like well that's like
that's way on the other other end of the
spectrum so I think it's um
I don't know it's finding again what's
like important for you right and like
and trying to distinguish between what
you've been taught and wired to think
and feel versus like your authentic self
and it's like you mentioned the word
wired the uh kindness and I was gonna
ask you about this because do you not
think I mean if we look at you know
cross-culturally almost every society
has some sort of uh I'm gonna quote
Jordan Peterson and get into a lot of
trouble here so I won't quite phrase it
the way he did which when he said
enforced monogamy and everybody went
mental but the idea that Society
encourages monogamous relationships
between men and women because that is
the the way that Society kind of you
know supports itself best and reproduces
itself best do you do you think maybe
part of this is just evolutionary and
evolutionary psychologically and
evolutionary biological in that we kind
of need people to to get together with
one person and and bring up children and
that's the most stable and safe
environment for that and therefore we
try to sort of moralize ourselves and
into a bit of a straight jacket that we
think is necessary
so I don't I'm obviously not an
evolutionary psychologist or
evolutionary biologist I've talked to
some of them and
I think it's interesting so I would say
what are the numbers I was just reading
this today
it's like almost like 80 percent of all
of the women that exist have had
children and only 40 percent of men that
have existed have had children so almost
all men like their lines have had
children with multiple women and the
vast majority of men have not had
children so if you just look at that
number it would suggest that monogamy
has not hasn't really existed in the way
that we think of it now where it's one
man one woman for the rest of their
lives like men have tended to kind of
stray so
I would say part of that is like
obviously the the consequence of sex for
a woman is huge especially especially
before you know birth control so that
definitely plays a factor into it
um and then I would say a lot of it too
is is so is social it's we have not been
allowed to be sexual you know outside of
rearing children
um until like the most recent years so I
think it's kind of a combination of both
and what do you make of the concept of
[ __ ] shaming uh this idea that women who
have sex with lots of men they are
unfairly treated because of their and
the there's nothing wrong with that at
all and and it should be sort of like
everybody should just do what what you
want
I think that it comes down to just being
a kind person right so I think it's the
wrong message to say there's absolutely
nothing wrong with sleeping with
everyone and anyone right like there
there's again some kind of boundary that
needs to happen I think someone that's
having like copious amounts of sex with
all of these strangers and they're not
being safe like there's something else
happening there I think that's very
different than somebody who may be like
casually dates or sleeps with more
people than the average bear or whatever
that's very different but I guess like
what is the purpose of the [ __ ] shaming
usually like if you're you know throwing
rocks at somebody else it has to do with
an insecurity that you have and I think
for a lot of women in particular is that
they for some reason they think that if
this one person is a little bit more
sexually loose or liberated than they
are than like what they have is at stake
so like you're now a direct threat to
like everything that I own and I'm
building in my family and that's just
um
I would say like that's kind of an
unjustified tie that they're making
hey Constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and KK get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
it's it's quite a tricky question do you
ever think that you you'll ever regret
your choices that you made maybe if you
want to go and do something else or if
you decide one day you want to become a
lawyer do you ever think that that means
that you would ever look back on your
career and think to yourself that was a
mistake or do you simply think it's part
of life's Rich tapestry as it were
yeah I would go with the latter I think
every decision that I made
um
I mean it was authentic and it was right
at the time and to go back and be like
well you know I regret this wouldn't
really make sense for me again it's it
is part of who I am
um I think it's unfortunate that I've
absolutely closed a lot of opportunities
by making that decision I mean even as
of late my husband and I were trying to
like start this business and it was
buying into this franchise and they were
like you can't do it because of you know
my career and it's like that's really
shitty and I can't get mad at them
because that's absolutely their right
and they have shareholders and all of
that like I totally understand them at
the same time I can be disappointed so I
I would say I'm not immune to being
disappointed because I don't get certain
things that I've strived for even you
know as of recently but it's just owning
my decisions
and but again it goes back to the
hypocrisy like where a company will go
well you know we don't want to be
associated with her with her but I
guarantee every one of those men on the
board every what men and women but
has has watched pornography every one of
those customers has watched pornography
and yet you want to buy into a franchise
in the business and you were someone who
have worked into creating that content
suddenly that's beyond the pale to me
that that doesn't make sense it doesn't
make any sense and you can't change
people you can only try to influence
them and I think you're gonna find
like-minded people if you look hard
enough right and it that just wasn't my
group that wasn't going to be someone
that was going to be supportive of me or
me as a franchisee so I've met other
people that own you know 100 plus
million dollar companies and their huge
Port Advocates so like I'm a huge a porn
fanatic and they go on to how they think
it's great for society and mental health
and all of these things and they get so
mad when they hear stories like that so
it's just finding people like that that
want to support you and help grow with
you and then just ignoring that and then
hoping that like that social climate
just like slowly keeps changing to where
it's not like this permanent red Edge
that I can't take off
and do you consider yourself a feminist
Candice
I don't even know what that means
anymore to be honest with us there's so
many different iterations of that I
would say probably not because most of
the ones that I've met I don't really
align with
um and maybe I'm meeting the wrong kind
of feminist like I don't hate men I
don't think that men are the same as
women I think that we're very different
I think that we need to appreciate those
differences
um when it comes to sex like I know
there's some feminists that are are very
anti-sex work and some that are very Pro
so I have no idea what that word even
means that's a very good answer actually
I'm very it sounds like an invasion but
actually it's exactly right because it's
become this broad concept and some
people use it pejoratively and some
people use it to praise people and and
they all mean different things I suppose
by the standard definition if you think
men and women are and should be treated
equally then everybody sort of is right
but but it seems to have got complicated
so do you find that feminists like you
or feminists hate you or you get
different reactions from different types
so like how what is your experience of
dealing with people I would say most of
them probably don't like me I've heard
that I've internalized the patriarch and
that I'm
um what is the other one
that like somehow I don't know that I'm
being exploited I like it's just it it
takes away all of the intelligence from
women like we we can't make these
decisions on our own we need someone to
hold our hand and we need someone
um to regulate this so that we don't
make this horrible mistake
um so to me that would be anti-women
right is saying that we are lesser than
we're Dumber then
um we're kind of like children in some
sense so I never really got along with
those women
and what have you learned from from your
journey in that particular industry
because it must have been an experience
where
how to put this you must have realized
things about yourself things about men
in particular things about sexuality
that the average person might never
might might never come across or might
never discover
um
oh man
that's a tough one
um
I would say that
I think we were sold this
story that you know if you owners your
sexuality and if you are pretty enough
or if you're rich enough if you're
famous enough all of these things that
that leads to I would say like being
fulfilled and happy I think when I first
got in and I first started getting
recognized it's almost like you start
getting drunk on all of those things and
you start losing touch with reality and
I think I learned that it's crucial and
imperative that you have people around
you to keep you grounded and to keep you
from floating away into that because
it's so easy to Lose Yourself when
you're
I guess trying to please other people
so I'd say one of the things I learned
the most was the value of like trying to
remain
I would say like
authentic and autonomous and like
finding your purpose and self-worth
internally versus trying to get those
external validations
um so I learned that probably magnified
right because you start getting all
these followers and you start getting
all of these comments and it's like very
easy to displace your values so I would
say like the importance of of your
values of your Social Circle
um and then I would say I'm just like
saying no like that was like the most
powerful thing I learned too in the
industry is like how to say no and no is
a complete sentence and you don't have
to explain anything and you have the
right to
um
to decide what to do with your body and
Candice it strikes me before we ask our
last question because our time is
running out it strikes me that you've of
you've had an experience of Life the
overwhelming majority of people haven't
had so as you look out into the the
broader culture and the political moment
and everything that's happening in the
world I imagine you have a very not a
very a unique view on it is there
anything that stands out for you now in
terms of what's happening in society
what the stuff that we're we're talking
about politically that you you feel
strongly about or have some input on
I have a lot of opinions
I would say I think it comes down to to
Freedom right and it's gonna sound super
vague and again
um no I just sound super American
but I think that that's it you have to
say like how much regulation do you want
on anything like what are you what are
you owed as a human being like what are
things that are yours that no one should
be able to take away
um and I think it's also important to
recognize like the the that goes for
your opponents too right so it's not
Freedom just to do the things that you
want and not the freedom for people to
do to do the things that you don't want
it kind of has to go across the board
and how do we co-exist together right
like that's also kind of something I've
had to deal with too especially living
in the South it's like how do you how do
you still be kind to someone with you
don't have to agree with my decisions or
my career or my views on sexual reality
to still treat me like a human being so
how do we take that you know ten
thousand feet away and say that maybe
from on a political scale like I might
not agree with who you voted for I might
not agree on the way that you look at
lockdown measurements but like we're
still all humans so how do we get back
to a place where we recognize that
Humanity especially in the people
opposite the end of the table of us
so that's a really really good it's a
really powerful yeah
it's true because at the moment we we
don't do that anymore we don't do that
we seem to have lost that ability
we've seem to have lost that ability and
it's really sad before before final
question is there anything that you
would change about the industry is there
anything that you would you would want
to just you know be improved
oh for sure I mean starting with pay
walls for any explicit content
um starting with the creators owning
their content and having like an equal
say as to whether it's published or
whether it gets taken down
um and then what we talked about earlier
which is if you decide that you know
that's no longer what represents you
that that content can be removed and it
can't be put back up so that people can
continue continue to grow evolve and
have a life after porn
well we're about to do a couple of
questions for our local so it's behind a
paywall so you'll approve of that but
before we do that we've got one final
question for you which is as always
what's the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
yeah and again I think it goes back to
to humanity and how do we recognize the
humanity and people that think different
that look different that
um maybe live different Lifestyles and
just going back to treating people like
people and being kind
it's interesting that that idea has
become quite like quite difficult for
people now because I always thought that
you know I'm from Russia originally I
and that was not something you have a
lot of
there it's certainly not in my
experience but coming to the West it was
sort of my my belief maybe naively and
mistakenly like this is the place where
that's what you do right like you can go
and be a porn star if that's what you
want to do and as long as you're not
being coerced or forced into it you know
I may agree or disagree or whatever but
there's you know you're a human being
I'm a human being you have the right to
do that I have the right to do a show
that people don't like whatever right
and we just seem to have kind of eroded
that quite recently do you have any
thoughts on why that is before we we
before we let you go
uh I don't know if it's like a single
factor I would definitely say it comes
back to maybe that social autism that
people are coining which is spending too
much time like on on screens unless
face-to-face time and we're not being
trained in like empathy and we're not
recognizing that anymore I think it's
very easy to be cruel when there's those
um different layers that like separate
us right it's so much easier to write a
nasty comment or a tweet than it is to
say something to someone's face so I
think it comes back to spending more
time grounded in the real world and less
time on your phone
that's a very good point uh Candace
where can people find your work online
before we ask you our other questions
um you can go to chatting with
candace.com and that has all my candid
socials or you can follow me on Twitter
which is where I spend way too much time
um which is Fallen louvia
fantastic uh so thank you very much for
coming on the show we really appreciate
your time uh and uh thank you for
watching and listening guys we'll see
you very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or all show all
of them go out at 7 p.m UK time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the Bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals Community using the
link below